Fatima's family is incomplete and torn
apart by a decision her brother made
nearly four years ago he left Jakarta
without notice taking his wife and
daughter with him to join ISIL
Vlada my brother isn't a violent person
my family isn't like that I was shocked
when they left if I had known of course
I wouldn't have approved he's now in
jail in Syria the Indonesian
government's decision to ban former ISIL
fighters and their families from
returning means she will likely never
see her brother again Allah says seize
the burger I want them back here I want
them to have a normal life in Indonesia
again among those stuck in Syria and
other countries are hundreds of
Indonesian ISIL fighters and
sympathizers and the question of what to
do with them is one the government has
considered for months and Birbhum brain
the government has the responsibility to
keep more than two hundred and sixty
seven million people safe that's our
priority and that's why we won't take
these foreign fighters back armed groups
are a major concern in Indonesia and
ISIL has been linked to dozens of
attacks around the country in 2018 a
family of suicide bombers carried out
attacks on churches in Surabaya they
were part of an ISIL inspired armed
group and there are fears returning
foreign fighters could pose a security
risk but some human rights activists say
barring them from returning to Indonesia
is illegal in initial constitutions the
obligation the main obligation of the
country is to protect protect all the
nations including the criminals if
they're criminals they're still in Asia
the strong stance of the Indonesian
government will leave hundreds stranded
with no prospect of returning home but
the fate of young children many of them
orphans remains unclear
the government says their situation will
be considered on a case-by-case basis
leaving the door open for their
potential return according to US
intelligence 689 people
left Indonesia to join ISIL Indonesian
authorities are working to identify them
Jessica Washington al Jazeera Jakarta